welcome to the world of Deus Ex for the
sake of this demo today we have infinite
energy infinite ammo
Alex duh hey you sound like [ __ ]
how you feeling little sore but alright
are you okay
uh yeah yeah I'm okay I've been through
worse
Jesus how [ __ ] up is that to think huh
listen Alex my systems are acting up a
little sir
I've gotta get checked out if you wanna
meet her what no no no I'm fine man you
just take care of you this girl's built
tough give me a call when you're useful
again okay talk to you soon
it's open blinds good morning Adam you
have one new message
from David Seraph play it Adam it's
David I know it's been a while but after
what happened in Prague yesterday look
son whatever reasons you've had for not
getting in touch his last two years well
life's too short I'm leaving for London
soon but give me
you saved us VidCon number yes Adam just
activate your TV system
Adam Jensen was caught in a terrorist
attack an hour 30 hours later and we
wake up in his apartment
Adam Jensen tries to recollect himself
he seems like he has some problems with
his augmentations and now he needs to
take care of that the thing is that in
the world of mankind divided in 2029 two
years after human Revolution and there
are a lot of problems in society a lot
of division a lot of tension and a lot
of companies like the Linn clinics that
are focusing on transhumanist
technologies are going bankrupt and now
Adam Jensen will have to rely on some
underground stuff
so Adam now is fresh she smells good is
clean is almost ready to go into his new
adventure but before we're going to look
around a little bit his apartment and
through that sec style there are plenty
of things to discover there are a lot of
readable x' buckets secretaries ebooks
computers where we can learn about Adam
Jensen's motivation the organization is
working for the state of the world
there's also a lot of emails that he can
read some of his colleagues at task
force 29 asking him to go see them
etcetera etcetera we're not going to
show all of the details today in the
apartment but for instance here we can
go onto the television we can watch the
news or you can even call back you're
all busted serif and that can unleash a
totally optional mission that is not
part of the critical path experience but
for today we're going to focus on the
main adventure and go out in the open
it's Jensen it's good to finally hear
from you agent you doing okay
sorry about the downtime I'll get to the
office as soon as I can but my dogs took
a hit during the attack I need to get
them looked at of course there's a lot
of work ahead of us Jensen I'll see you
when you get in
dr. Carlin I need to pay you a visit
Jensen now is actually a really good
time for me like right now something
there are some guys in my book shop P
stuff the valley gangster looking guys
so unless you want bloodshed the day
after a terror attack the front door
isn't the most peaceful option I got it
so it seems Jensen's friend václav
cooler has some problem with local
mobsters we're going to go shortly to
see what's going on there but in the
meantime we're going to look a little
bit at the city here were still in the
apartment complex where Adam Jensen
lives of course we can explore all the
apartments and discover loot discover
story about a lot of things now we're in
the city of itself we're in the poor
district of Prague and there's a lot of
augmented people living in that district
as you can see there are a lot of police
forces looking around and making sure
that everybody is thinking check there's
a lot of paranoia there's a lot of
tension
license permit voucher document of
authority temporary pass travel coupon
and or certificate of authenticity good
old days we just asked for ID good old
days are gone
haven't seen one of these before orange
level you are some kind of badass just
someone with a job to do
and the tools to do it obviously go on
through
fortunately Adam Johnson has his papers
in order but he's still an Augmented
citizen and there is no discrimination
on that and like police are going to
check everything and make sure that
you're complying to what's needed
because in this world police are just
looking for an excuse to send you to
some ghettos here we can see the metro
station it's another example where the
segregation is institutionalized we have
the natural line and also we have the
Augmented line to take the subway if you
take the line for the Naturals chances
are that the police are going to ask
your papers and they're going to arrest
you but if you use the line for
Augmented citizen you'll be able to
breeze your way through and get to the
district you want to go without being
bothered
and through their sex fashion you can
talk to all the characters in the world
you can learn more about their own
stories about some of the things
happening in the world you can also get
some hints about certain places etc so
it's up to you to discover all these
things now we're getting close to our
friend
václav Koehler and we're going to show
you some of the options to get to him
there are always more than one way to
get where we want to go there's a
blockade here let's see what it is
karate
look laddie so my latest papers
otherwise you cannot go through
I know the Jerome
for the sake of this demo we just
shortened this conversation but
basically what you discover is that
those police officers want you to pay
some fee to go around and get to your
destination as you go and explore that
side mission depending on how you play
can be a very short story that can last
maybe 10 15 minutes but you can dig
deeper and deeper and end up into a
story that can spawn for over an hour
and your discover that those fake police
officers are extorting augmented people
that are out of hope and you'll be able
to make a difference we're going to look
at the right side of the police blockade
and it seems like there is another path
so let's explore it to see what it is I
would have found him straightest
off-limits or your book Revit function
all businesses are temporarily closed it
seems that those guys are the the valley
gangsters our friend Kohler was talking
about so since we don't want to create
chaos here today we're going to look for
another option in mankind divided we
really wanted to expand on the
exploration aspect of the game and
verticality is a big part of it and as
you see here there's an apartment
upstairs with a flickering light and
there's probably a way to get there and
also to go around the blockades that
we've seen and maybe get to our friend
without disrupting the peace in the city
that's an example on how we can exploit
the verticality there are objects in the
world that we can interact with and now
we're able to reach higher ground
depending are aware of the augmentations
that you have you might be able to get
there without the use of the environment
so depending on how you build your
dungeons and how you decide to exploit
these capabilities you'll be able to get
in places in different ways or none at
all as you can see here something happen
and that is a story that we're not going
to fully explore today but as you play
the game you'll be able to understand
what happened with those people hacking
is back like in human revolution you
have to go from one end of the network
to be read in just one around security
systems as more protections that you
have to overcome like booby traps but
also as a player you're going to have
more software's to use to try to
circumvent the challenges I can tell you
that this time around the gameplay is
going to be more tactical than it was in
the last game so it's going to require a
little bit more skills to hack some of
those networks let's continue to our
friend color and yes Adam Jensen loves
air vents exploring all around and all
in the little corners of the map is
really important because you can find a
lot of loot a lot of secret things and
here for example we have a pocket
secretary we're not going to open it
today but it's just to show you that
those little devices have codes
passwords things like that that can
allow you to get to secret places that
otherwise would be more difficult to
reach so now we've passed our friends to
the valving mobsters and also we passed
around the police blockade and now we're
getting close to our objective
this is the time machine it's a bookshop
that is owned by václav Kohler and now
is the valley friends are trying to find
him the thing is that he's hiding
somewhere in his building and now
they're trashing the place shooting
everywhere trying to make him come out
of his hiding because apparently owes
them money this is the smart vision you
can see the weapons enemies carry the
loot they have if they have pockets
secretaries the can of ammo they have so
it can be really interesting if you're
the kind of tactical player to know
which ones are more interesting to take
down or not depend on your playstyle
so today we're not going to pass through
the main door because we don't want to
start the fight right away we're going
to start our way around with cloaking I
was talking about verticality so it
means that when you fall from higher
ground you make more noise and enemies
can hear the noise you're producing so
even if you're using like here the
cloaking even if they don't see you they
will hear you so it can be a very good
idea to combine different augmentations
together to have an added value so in
this case not only you're totally
invincible but people cannot hear you at
all so you're the perfect stealth agent
takedowns are back lethal or non-lethal
as always but this time around mal you
can perform them from color we avoided
the main entry point to get to our
friends so there's the delivery entrance
here but the door is locked
we're going to look for another option
to get in but seems that we have an
opening on the roof and what is
important is that when you get to a
location like color time-machine
there are always more than one way to
get inside looking at your environment
is really key for your success
now we're using the test slug gun arm
which is a new augmentation that Adam
Jensen has that allows us to take down
enemies not literally and when you fully
upgrade this augmentation you can take
out up to four enemies at once it can be
really interesting especially if you're
a non-lethal fighter
I love cats here the stun gun as you're
going to see it as a similar effect as
the Tesla gun arm but it shoots one
single bullet at once and you have to be
at very close range to hit your targets
so depending on your gameplay style you
might want to invest in the gun arm or
you might want to keep those practices
points for other Ragman tations and you
rely on the stun gun so it's really up
to the players to really craft the ax
dungeons in the wall here we could have
gone through that bookshelf that is on
the side and we could have climbed up to
the second floor but for today's
presentation we're going to take a
different path
we just use the silenced pistol which
can be very deadly and very quiet
here's another gun armed nano Blade gun
arm allows you to trow the nano blades
and you can kill very quickly and
without too much noise enemies and also
you can have an upgrade that allows you
to really charge the nano blade and once
you shoot it it's going to explode after
few seconds and you can take down
several of these at once because it has
a 360 effect we're getting closer to our
objective and now we just use a toxic
gas grenade and everybody in the radius
of the grenade is going to be affected
this guy has been lucky until now
fortunately for this the more Adam
Johnson at the augmentation that
protects you against it otherwise you
would have suffered from the same
consequences as our Diwali friends
now we're in colors office apparently
the mobsters looked around but they
didn't find the secret spot to find :
Jensen
thank God I'm down in the dungeon man
you remember the title of my super
secret book right I remember it's read
earlier on I was talking about redoubles
in the universe and here we have another
example newspapers there are different
stories that you can discover and some
of those stories can be influenced by
what you achieve yourself and some side
missions or even on the critical path
here our Diwali friends forgot to look
at this weird red book it seems that
colour loves augmentations quite a bit
here's colors lab and I was talking
about exploration earlier there are
always secrets to find and here you have
another example Denson my favorite take
no wonder the kind is sorry about the
goons man nothing I couldn't handle
that's it for today I hope you enjoyed
that demo the game is out on August 23rd
see you soon